so over the weekend SUNY Buffalo Buffalo
State and Upstate New York reportedly
evicting four dozen migrants why parents
raised concerns about the safety of the
students going back to school can you
blame them and as the chaos continues at
our nation's border the southern border
not the northern border is bad too but
Southern obviously worse President Biden
now has been selling off parts of
Trump's unfinished border wall that was
contracted to be 400 miles long this is
an apparent bid to thwart new GOP
legislation which calls for the federal
government to either use the material or
give them give the states that will
that's New Mexico Texas or Arizona or
California now keep in mind this past
the Senate is Republican sponsored bill
but it passed with Democratic support it
just needed to be offered to the house
and passed in the fall Senator Tom
Godden joins us now he sponsored the
legislation Senator this is outrageous
what's going on
Brian it really is outrageous you can't
make it up the Biden Administration
inherited around 260 million dollars
worth of border construction materials
from the Trump Administration they
immediately put it in storage on day one
when Donald or when Joe Biden said he
wasn't going to build the wall they've
now paid 300 million dollars to store it
for two years more than the cost of
material themselves but as soon as
Senate Republicans led by Senator Roger
wicker who is the leader of Republicans
in the armed services committee began
poking around and asking questions about
it earlier this year the administration
began to sell these materials for less
than two cents on the dollar the
legislation that you mentioned is
Senator Wicker's legislation which I was
pleased to join it was it added
unanimously by democrats on the armed
services committee to our annual defense
Bill and now the administration is
racing to try to sell off all of these
materials because they would rather have
taxpayers take a massive loss of
hundreds of millions of dollars then
give them to the governor of Texas for
instance to build the border wall or to
allow them to be sitting around and used
to build a border wall when Republicans
take back the White House in January of
2025. so this is pure Vengeance no one
thinks that a wall solves all the
problems but it blocks and it funnels to
other areas which can be staffed and
they're not fully staffed they're being
overwhelmed we pay for this and they're
wasting this this gov Planet Line
Auction House has picked up the faces
you mentioned they have sold 81 slots
already 30 feet high 154 million dollars
of the 260 million dollar Bollard fence
so this is awful anybody buying this
scrap steel it's an unpatriotic move if
you care about our nation's borders if
you are a major corporation don't show
up for this auction
yeah Brian and apparently the
administration is trying to silence the
auction house as well you know this is a
fairly typical operation for things like
excess meals ready to eat or excess
ponchos that's why we have Army surplus
stores around the country that sell
these materials it's a horse of a
different color when you're talking
about barrier material to try to protect
our Southern border I mean in the last
two years Joe Biden has allowed at least
250 people on the Terrace watch list or
arrive at our Southern border that's not
even counting the people who the border
patrol didn't catch so we have no idea
how many terrorists have entered our
country at the same time we're selling
this material for pennies on the dollar
that's kind of bidenomics in a nutshell
the total lack of Common Sense yeah uh
total lack common sense and in terms of
Roger wicker the senator says it shows
they have no shame I just went to
something legal you can do to stop them
from wasting taxpayer money and
thwarting legislation that have been
passed and repurposed for this purpose
hopefully you'll find something Senator
before it's too late thanks so much for
joining us
thank you Brian I'm Steve Ducey I'm
Brian Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley Earhart
and click here to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis